now we're going to cover a really
important circuit in electronics it's
the resistor capacitor circuit or rc
circuit and in particular in this video
we're going to talk about
the natural response of an rc circuit
the natural response is what happens
when you put some initial energy into
the circuit and in the case of an rc
circuit it represents charge that's
stored on the capacitor at the beginning
of the analysis
we're going to go through an intuitive
description of what happens in this
circuit when this switch is
changed from this position where we're
connecting a battery to the rc
combination and then we're going to
basically move the switch over to here
and watch what happens as that capacitor
discharges through back through the
resistor
and that discharge pattern is called the
natural response
so let's look at the circuit as it's
sitting here right now let's say that
the switch has been in this position for
a really long time
now sometime in the past there was some
sort of a current that flowed out of
here
that current flowed through the resistor
and onto this capacitor
right here
and that left us with some charge
there's some charge here
and what that looks like let's do a
close-up picture of the capacitor
as charge flowed in here
it piled up on this side of the
capacitor
and there's a corresponding negative
charge
that collected on the other side
this amount of charge matches this
amount of charge so that's what we mean
when we say
that q or charge is collecting on a
capacitor
and for a capacitor structure we know
that the amount of charge here is equal
to the capacitance value
times the voltage
so as more and more
charge accumulates here
the voltage goes up
c is fixed it's a property of the
capacitor
if charge goes up then v goes up
so let's go back over here and see what
happens
as this current flows onto the capacitor
charge accumulates and eventually
this voltage here will rise up to be
plus
and minus v naught
and at that point when this points at v
naught and this point is at v naught the
current through the resistor stops
so the current here will be zero and the
voltage at this point will be v naught
so i want to plot that right now we'll
begin our sketch
of what this response looks like
so this is this will be our time axis
this will be v of t
which is this voltage here
and this will be i of t
and we're going to label i of t to be
this current here
and you'll see why i picked that
direction in a minute
all right so
at the beginning
before i throw the switch before we're
going to throw the switch in this
direction right here in a minute but
before we do that we have v naught on
the capacitor
and we have i of t equals to zero so let
me fill those in
before time equals zero this is equal to
v naught
and this current down here
is zero
so now we're ready to throw the switch
let me do that
we'll erase this
and then put the switch in
this position here
and now let me clean this up i'm going
to erase the battery here the battery's
done its job for us which was to
initially put some charge on our
capacitor so we don't need this anymore
so here's our simplified circuit
and what we have here there's a bunch of
charge stored on c and what's going to
happen
it's going to start rushing out of the
capacitor and going back through the
resistor
to basically come over here and
neutralize the charge on the bottom
plate
what's going to happen is over here
the
charge is going to leave it's going to
go over through the resistor come back
in here and these pluses and minuses
will then be neutralized and that means
if there's no net charge
the voltage is going to go to zero
so we can draw that what we're going to
say is
after all this charge rushes out of here
goes through the resistor
and ends up on the back side of the
capacitor neutralizing the charge in the
circuit
that means the voltage in the circuit is
going to be zero so we can draw that we
draw the long time from now
out here it's going to sketch into
something like that it's going to be low
likewise the current is going to end up
at zero when we're finished here and
that's what happens with every natural
response
it basically the energy in the circuit
is allowed to die to zero
so let's see if we can fill in what's
going to happen in between
well this voltage here started at v
naught
and it's going to end up at zero and
the amount of current flowing out of
here is going to be proportional to the
voltage across this resistor
right
the amount of current flowing out
is 1 over r
times v
so if if v is high
then i is going to be high and as v goes
down as we use up our charge the
current's going to go down so i can sort
of guess what's going to happen here
it's going to basically come down
and end up somehow at zero
after a while
now we don't know how long it's going to
take yet
but
it's going to have some shape like this
so let's look at what the current's
going to do the current right now when
the switch was thrown is at 0.
as soon as that switch is thrown as soon
as we connect it right here all of a
sudden we have v naught on this side of
the resistor
and
zero on this side of the resistor and so
there's going to be a sharp current
increase going through this resistor
here so we expect this to go up like
that to jump up to some value
what we think the current's going to
look like the current is actually over
here it's directly proportional to the
voltage so as the voltage goes down
the current is going to go down
and we can take a guess it's going to
have a pretty much it'll have the same
shape as the voltage so it's going to go
down something like that
until it dies out to zero
so this is our forecast for what the
natural response of an rc circuit looks
like and in the next video we will
actually derive really precise
expressions for what those two curves
look like